مباراه امس فوز السعوديه كان شئ تاريخي
الفيفا وصفتها باكبر مفاجاه التاريخ كاس
العالم ومحللين اعتبروها اهم مباراه وفوز
عربي في تاريخ المونديال لكن الى جانب
الانجاز الرياضي وتصدر المجموعه حتى الان
ناس كثير جلسه بتتكلم عن ابعاد اكبر من
هذه المباراه والنتيجه همم نحنا بنتكلم عن
ابعاد اعلاميه تسويقيه اقتصاديه كل هذه
الابعاد للفوز موجوده وبيشرحوا كيف انه
هذه المباراه بتعكس اهميه الرياضه وكيف
انه لها تداعيات بتتجاوز المنافسات
الرياضيه والالقاب فقط ومن هؤلاء مستشار
التسويق دكتور محمد حتحوط اللي يغرد وقال
انه المباراه لها اثر اعلامي وتشويقي يفوق
30 همم مليار ويمكن
تسويقي تحديدا يمكن خلينا بس لو انه هذه
لها المباراه اثر اعلامي وتسويقي تحديدا
بيثوق الثلاثين مليار يمكن الضعف المبلغ
كمان طيب خلينا نفهم منه كيف اكثر يقصد
طيب من الرياض ينضم الينا مستشاره التسويق
دكتور محمد حتحوت اهلا فيك معانا دكتور
محمد انت كنت حاضر صحيح
كانت مباراه تاريخيه من كل التفاصيل
الجماهير الحضور الاداء المشرف في منتخبنا
وفي اثناء المباراه وفي نهايتها قلت
الزملاء احنا يمكن لا مو مستوعبين اللي
صار وهذه المباراه
اجمل مباراه حضرتها في حياتي وقلت لهم في
المباراه ما اتوقع انه في المستقبل قد
نحفظ المباراه بهذا الجمال اللي صار
تاريخي كان استثنائي نحتفل فيه ونفتخر فيك
السعوديه
والتسويقي اللي قلت انه ممكن حتى نقدروا
بما يفوق ال 30 مليون ايش تقصد بهذا الشيء
وكيف حسب موضوع الثلاثين مليار عادي
اول شيء استاذه ساره لازم نعرف شغله اللي
هي النيشان براندينج او العلامه الوطنيه
اليوم هذا اصبح توبك في اخر خنقول 25 سنه
عند كل الدول اليوم كوريا كمثال جنوبيهم
فوق 1% من داخلها فقط لتسويق الثقافه
الكوريه اليوم المانيا عندها جهاز متخصص
لتصدير همم الاسم الالماني امريكا كذلك
اوروبا ماليزيا جنوب افريقيا روسيا الصين
الدول كلها تهتم بعلاماتها الوطنيه وبناء
علامات الوطنيه بشكل واعي وعندها اهداف
وين تبغى تبني وين تبغى يكون لها دور لانه
لسبب بسيط بدون اكتشفت انه هذا الاسم
الاسم دولهتك والصول يحملها الناس في
اذهانم حول العالم عن هذا البراند او هذا
الاسم لو بعد اقتصادي نعم لما تقول والله
صنع في الصين او صنع في اليابان او صنع في
المانيا او صنع في امريكا او في ايطاليا
لاحظ كل واحد مشاهدينا الساده اليوم عنده
انطباعات كتسلسله صور كده امام وسريعه
تيجي لما اقول الصين او اليابان او
الدنمارك او امريكا او المانيا هذه الصور
لها اثر اقتصاد بمعنى لو ممكن ادفع على
شيء في اليابان ثلاث اربع اضعاف يمكن نفس
المنتج في الصين اليوم العلامه الوطنيه
الاهتمام فيها لم يعترف انا ولا شيء ثاني
وتدور تهتم بشكل مباشر لانه لها اثر
اقتصادي مباشر عليها اللي صار امس ايوه
بحسبه بسيطه احنا في التسويق عندنا انواع
من الوصول للناس عندك النوع الاول اللي هو
البريد ميديا او الاعلام المدفوعه
والاعلان المدفوع سواء سواء خلال القنوات
اعلاميه اعلانات مدفوعه الى اخره واضح
حسبته جزء من الحسبه التسويقيه شيء نسميه
الاعلام المكتسب
او او القرد ميديا حسبه اقتصاديه بمعنى
اخر عشان نبصلها للساده المشاهدين انا امس
يمكن اليوم في اخر ثمانيه عشر ساعات مع
امس كله جالس ابحث فقط باللغه الانجليزيه
باللغه
الاسبانيه اللغات الاخرى الهنديه فقط بحث
بالعربيه والانجليزيه فقط
كميه التفاعل يعني ما في قناه عالميه او
صحيفه مرموقه او موقع معروف سواء مختص
بالرياضه او لا الا اتحدث عن هذا الحدث
هذا سميه اعلام مكتسب هذا لو قلنا نبغى
نشتريه لو كان قيمه السوقيه هذا في طريقه
نتكلم كيف تحسبها له طريقه تقول له تفاصيل
ومنهجاته لكن كحسبه بسيطه جدا تفوق ال 30
مليار خليني اعطيك مثال اصغر يوضح الصوره
مطعم ماك مطعم معروف في امريكا في يوم
المراه العالمي حرف الام حقه وهذا قلبي
اللي هو اول كل حرف من كلمه اومن يعني
تفاعلا مع يوم المراه العالمي جاء تغطيه
اعلاميه على مستوى العالمي اقل بكثير ولا
يجي ولا 10% من اللي صار السعوديه امس
فلما جاؤوا في الاد ايج وغيرها من جهات
التسويقيه المتخصصه تبقى تحسب كم القيمه
التسويقيه اللي حصل عليها مطعم ماك
مقابلها التغطيه المجاني لجاتوه حسب
تقريبا باربعه مليار
الساده اول مره يسمع القصه هذه
اللي صار
بدي اسالك على شيء انت كتبته انه حتى
المقاطع اللي فيها سخريه لا مفيده برده
لانها تصنع صوره ايجابيه الحدث الان الحمد
لله احيانا قد يصعد شخص على الستيج
العالمي بس انه بصوره سلبيه نحنا بصوره
ايجابيه وحتى المقاطع الساخره هي تسخر من
الارجنتين لكنها ترفع من شعبيه واسم
السعوديه انا متاكد اليوم اي سائح سيذهب
العالم اي دوله في العالم الايام هذه او
حتى الفتره القادمه من السعوديه سيفتح
نقاش مباشره على موضوع الارجنتين
والسعوديه فانتقعت تغير اذان الناس قناعات
الناس عن السعوديين دوله اليوم قادره دوله
ستفاجئ باشياء لم تتوقع منها على المسرح
الدولي في ملعب شاهدوا امس فوق الخمسه
مليار حسن احصائيه الفيفا يشاهد مباريات
كاس العالم
ستتفاجئك ايضا باشياء اخرى طيب احنا
بنشكرك على هذه النظره المختلفه والشامله
لحدث امس كان معنا من الرياض مستشار
التسويق دكتور محمد حتحوت شكرا لك يا
دكتور
[موسيقى]